it never gets any easier sorry no you
don't have to apologize sorry has
anybody ever taken their clothes off on
this
[Music]
thing hey what's going on and Happy
Thanksgiving everybody for first we
Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Sebastian
Maniscalco he's one of stand-up comedy's
biggest acts with six specials to his
name his latest is it m is currently
streaming on Netflix check out the Pete
and as show on YouTube or wherever you
get your podcast and he also stars in a
brand new comedy series coming to HBO
Max it's called bookie and it premieres
on November 30th Sebastian Maniscalco
welcome to the show oh thanks for having
me on what's going through your head as
you prepare to take on The Gauntlet are
you someone who naturally reaches for
the hot sauce I like hot sauce uh on my
eggs actually in the morning but uh
nothing quite like these look
threatening right um but I'm I'm a
little nervous to be honest with you um
I have stuff to do after this today and
I'm hoping I make those
[Music]
commitments okay to
handle I tell
[Music]
you first one is like um something that
you would get at your um your bar you're
watching your game and this is what
comes out exactly that's what this is
equivalent
[Music]
to no problem so in your new show bookie
you play the role of a bookmaker chasing
down unpaid debts from dubious
characters and Reckoning with an
uncertain future as sports betting
becomes legalized what if any anything
of you picked up on the insights Inside
the Mind of a bookie or a gambler
spending so much time performing in
cities like Atlantic City and Las Vegas
I used to gamble uh myself um this is
when I was waiting tables at the Four
Seasons Hotel I would go to Vegas maybe
once a month to see if I could beat the
casino my my whole mindset was hey if I
win $1,000 this weekend I could take a
week off from waiting tables and do what
I want to do which was comedy
that never
worked so um yeah I could have won more
money that I was making but now it
brings me absolutely no joy and the only
way you could walk out of a casino with
money is performing at it so that's the
route I
[Music]
took oh yeah
shashido
no I noticed Matt Dam when you had him
on was chucking his wings into this
garbage can yeah what's the
etiquette on an eaten Wing do we leave
it on the on the table or you know I do
because you know we roll out the red
carpet treatment for our guest but over
here I'm blind oh I actually do have a
garbage can maybe I just never noticed
it until now but I kind of leave them on
the board you leave them on the board
okay I'm leaving mine on the board I
don't know I don't know if you're
picking this up on the camera here the
the eaten ones but if it's looking awful
let me know I'll start
discarding so like you I'm a product of
Chicago's northwest suburbs growing up
did you have a favorite Regional TV
commercial when we had Bob Odenkirk on
the show he shout out Scher Ford but I'm
kind of like a RoR and Bob rorman guy or
I like the Empire jingle a lot I'm with
you with the Empire 5
58300 Empire still remember that from 8
years old uh there's also a commercial I
forget the the actual I think it was for
auto insurance they had a guy to go and
get in a car and the door fell off the
car I don't remember what commercial
that was for that was like a some some
auto insurance company uh back in the
day I'm trying to wrap my brain around
is that Eagleman like must call eag
another one Eagle Eagle man too yeah
like a hawk that flew on the woman's
shoulder um came in kind of a
mascot uh pillo for is it
this is regional humor people I don't
know if anybody else is getting this but
we're having a bowl uh but yeah those
are probably my favorites growing
up I think you guys forgot to Sauce that
up I'm not feeling nothing on that by
the way have to point out I know on a
lot of your shows it's just a black uh
tablecloth yeah who's ever doing a set
design here has to be commended not only
for the beautiful fringe
yes pumpkin glass it's in the details
over here D it's in the details with dom
thanks
D so Melissa McCarthy was on the show
she told me that one of her comedy cheat
codes is people watching the aisles of
Big Lot stores as you become successful
do you still purposefully do everyday
things like go to the grocery store to
get new material yeah I try to put
myself in a lot of these moments to
extract material obviously it's a little
bit more difficult now than it was when
I had nothing to do I literally had
nothing to do between
1998 and 2005 not busy I would go to
Target I would just walk around a
bookstore looking for self-help books
you know just you know lost right uh and
I would run into material but now that
I'm doing uh you know popular shows like
hot ones who's got the time
uh but yeah I uh I like humor from
everyday situations I think people could
relate to that type of humor I've
concentrated a lot of my humor now on
family and parenting and being a father
so that's kind of serving me well but I
always love those moments where I'm like
oh this is like an everyday
[Music]
occurrence so you guys are producing
your own
but if you don't like it you can let us
know it's not a matter of liking or
disliking with the hot it's like am I
going to have a problem with this later
on or is it manageable throughout the
interview right and you know what
knocking down the fourth wall here this
is a 10: a.m. shoot very early hot one
shoot and it's Brave of you Sebastian
you know what I'm I'm actually some
something's
happening as I'm talking I I'm out of
breath breath and uh I don't know if
that's a side effect the show the show
or I'm passing away it could be either
either so where was I I I I literally
felt like lightheaded but go ahead yeah
yeah how do you know if an hour of
Comedy is hitting like is it uh feel in
the room is it critics is it a trusted
Inner Circle like what is the focus
group testing of it it takes a while to
get your set to be funny from front to
back you know you don't like to have
lulls you don't like to lose the
attention of the audience so what I like
to do is have the next joke be as good
or better than the last one uh and it's
difficult it's difficult to do and and
in this day and age where everything's
out there it's on the internet people
have seen it and if they go to a show
God forbid they see a joke that they saw
on the internet you know they're like
what what are we paying for you know so
you really got to like shurn the wheels
and crank out material faster than you
would have in you know the 1980s that
makes sense to me are you ready to move
on here to Sauce number five halfway
mark yeah this is the uh jablo Power jab
and this is kind of a step up okay not
to lead the witness all
[Music]
right yeah that's a step
up oh great I'm sweating so much the
microphone fell off my
chest you kidding
relax oh my
god oh okay so prior to your
breakthrough in Hollywood I understand
that you worked as a waiter at the Four
Seasons for seven years which is a more
Savage Group Comedy Club hecklers or
disgruntled diners wow man no one's ever
asked me that question and it really uh
is a good one I would perform in front
of hecklers any day of the week rather
than people that waiting on people
waiting on people if you're ever in the
hospitality business you well know that
people's requests are obscene and absurd
and I imagine at the Four Seasons That's
like another level to that just the way
people we used to give them a free nut
caddy right you put a nut caddy and it
had wasabi peas almonds people were
eating this like an appetizer right and
they would they would uh one woman I
remember would flag me down she goes
could could we get a little bit more of
the poo tray oh God I had a rash down
the back of my spine the rest of the
shift uh so I would get extremely
irritated with these requests one woman
didn't like the wine glass she felt the
the the the brim of the wine glass was
too thick to place on our lips did we
have a thinner wine glass so after
hearing these requests for seven years
I'll take a Heckler any day of the
week
H sauce is that yeah yeah yeah it's a
whiskey smoked ghost here in the six
[Music]
SP by the way I don't like that you call
this a
gauntlet if we could change the name
that would how about like a lineup great
little softer around the Ed gaet just
sounds like death I'll soften the edges
for you over here
okay yeah it's uh that's um it's good
it's good I like it but um but kind of
some late life on this one late life you
know yeah a little time release and then
it hits is it true that someone once
took off their shirt and wanted to fight
you yeah during a show is that the most
hostile reaction to your standup that
you ever experienced yeah that was at
The Comedy Store early on there was a
guy sorry it's not no need to apologize
it's not the fact that I don't know
where the story is going it's the fact
that I don't know how loud the belch was
going to
be uh yeah I was doing some crowd work I
was kind of making light of the their
relationship or I don't know exactly
what I said but this guy took his shirt
off wanted to fight me and then he was
escorted out uh so that was the only
thing that I was like oh wow this this
could get weird up here uh other than
that though knock on wood haven't had
really any any issues on stage that's
good and been doing it for a long time
it's good to just have that one all
right Sebastian you ready to move on
here to Sauce number seven oh this is
the goat this is the goat is your goat
Tropic star mhm here we
go by the way when you had Foley on that
guy did not seem phased at all I mean I
don't know what the hell that guy's made
out of but he was eating this like it
was
cereal it's hot $10 left chug this whole
bot well I guess when you get body
slammed on thumb tacks this is not that
yeah like what's what's the hot ones
Gauntlet there you go again there you
go what do you think is your dad's
favorite part of being famous you know
hearing some of your stories it seems
like you know he's maybe more into the
trappings of success than you are yeah
so my dad will go out to a um a
restaurant and try and get noticed right
he'll like throw the last name around
like it's that's going to like hold some
weight uh you know he says I went to a
restaurant last night and made a
reservation on a Mana scalco no free
dessert I why I don't even get free
dessert what you know so he he's uh he's
my biggest fan he's my biggest critic I
I don't get a big head at all with him
in my life actually with everybody in my
life you know there's no way they're
afraid if they say that's a good job I'm
going to just rest on that and not come
up with any new material so they're
always on my ass to you know keep
creating these people are spending a lot
of money to come and see you you know
you know they paid for parking
babysitter you know this is my father
I'm 50 this is what he's telling me that
they paid for parking what so yeah I
always uh I always try to give my best
up there because I know you know people
coming out to see me it's not you know
people coming all the way from whatever
New York to Atlantic City tonight to
come and see me so I want to make sure
they get a great
[Music]
show
this Wing is very very hot okay
[Music]
great I tell already it's going to be a
problem it's immediate yeah give me him
it's [__] awful and never get easier
I'm sorry no you don't have to apologize
sorry has anybody ever taken their
clothes off on this
thing why do you think you might be
breaking new ground here no this is
um I know know C it's a natural reaction
on the show and then this is where I'll
just say be careful around the eyes you
know like naturally you'll want to swipe
but you've been eating you don't want to
mace yourself all right all right and
don't worry while you absorb that this
has a nice long wind up so I reached out
to a mutual friend of ours jool Puma
yeah one second I don't know if you guys
are feeling this in the room but I feel
the room is
nervous are you feeling
that okay sorry auma yeah well reached
out to jol lauma to see if he had any
dirt on you while preparing for this
interview he was very tight lipped did
not want to violate the trust but did
let it slip that he'll sometimes work as
a DJ Khaled interpreter for you yeah so
on this Wing what I want to do is Bounce
a few DJ khed quotes off of you just to
see if you can maybe try to explain the
greater meaning as best you can does
that sound good all right let's do it
all right first things first to my fans
I promise you if I quit it doesn't mean
I gave up what do you think that means
this is why I need an
interpreter I'm like half in this half
out of it to be honest with you I'm
listening to the question but then I'm
wondering what am I when is there a tear
going to drop yeah no I get it and that
is a total that is a totally normal
reaction to be I get a little weightless
around this time you know I get a little
floaty how about this one the key to
more success is cocoa butter agree or
disagree you know what it is cocoa
butter for me I put some on this morning
and uh feel great and uh feel like my
career is going to take
off how about this you got to water your
plants nobody can water them for
you you got to water your plants cuz no
one's going to water them for you you
know
what someone Waters my
plants it's a hole in the logic on that
one I got one more for you I got one
more for you them doors that was always
closed I ripped the doors off took the
hinges off and when I took the hinges
off I put the hinges in the [__] boy's
hands wow wow he said that on this show
oh he did yeah and what was your
response to that in the fog it's like
you know uh a door being closed that we
all know you know like I'm going for
opportunity I'm grabbing door knobs none
of them are open for me you know like
the door doesn't open for I get I get
yeah he opened the door he ripped he
ripped the door off
my question is who's [__] boy so I think
[__] boy is the guy who kept the door
closed on you right so it's like they're
going to close the door on me they're
going to lock the door on me you know
what I'm going to do I'm going to rip
open the door but I'm not even going to
stop there I'm going to take the hinges
off of the frame and then I'm going to
give the hinges to the person who was
closing the door in my face but that's
just me kind of freestyling I don't
really that was a good
freestyle God dud
whatever that
means Austin's Hot
[Music]
Sauce kind of sweet up
front I don't know what to tell you
after you get through the last one
nothing's that much of a block you know
it was so bad the I got to say the the
bomb yeah was so
bad that didn't feel at all bad I I
don't know if it's just adding or just
kind of the same yeah well I think the
bomb kicks open that door rips the
hinges off puts in the [__] boy's hands
you can walk through anything after that
I got to tell you what a great call back
what a great call
back from boxing rings to fine dining
restaurants to dry cleaners what's the
most bizarre venue you've ever performed
comedy in and what if anything do you
remember about how the show went there
was a boxing ring in oh God was it
mentia California is the heroin capital
of the world I believe and I'm in a
boxing ring with a bowling alley behind
me so this is when someone said hey we
got a gig for you in Mantika for a 100
bucks you want it you know where's
Mantika you you just got into the boxing
ring people were watching sports
and you go hey everybody and then people
are like oh what's going on and and and
you start doing comedy right but in the
background someone's picking up a
spare right so you had bowling pins
going down you had drunk people at the
bar watching sports and then like comedy
in a boxing ring and with like fresh
blood from the night before underneath
your feet so yeah that was probably the
worst but you got to do those gigs this
is the problem with comedy today is I
think with the internet with the Tik
toks and the Instagram maybe people
aren't getting out there that experience
that kind of experience you got to go
through that you got to go through that
in order to handle the guy that's going
to take his shirt off and wants to fight
you two years L uh later you know what
I'm saying like you need that experience
and sometimes today I think that a lot
of this experience happens in their your
living room and you're with with a ring
light
and you're doing whatever you're doing
and I'm not knocking it I'm just saying
live performance there's no substitute
you got to put the hours and to be a
seasoned comedian and at the end of the
day 100 bucks is 100 bucks smashion Mas
shaking it
up okay this is going to be just a
that are you getting that just just a
just a there you goaz perfect
okay Cheers
[Music]
Cheers I know not
B it's not bad the the bomb killed me
right killed me and then after that
everything we got we got a there's an
after effect here on this yeah
yeah I thought it was I thought it I
thought I made it what it's like uh
sauces when you talk about it it's
almost like they hear you sometimes you
know yeah this definitely heard me and
to close things out I think it's only
right to celebrate the holiday with the
Sebastian Maniscalco guide to
Thanksgiving Straight From the Source
what are your thoughts on guests
bringing pre-prepared casseroles and
side dishes like is that a gesture of
Goodwill or just kind of gross if I'm
hosting let me handle it all right from
front to back I got the food therez a
lot of times people bring food in and
the presentation of it is terrible right
it gets a little lost in transit there
yeah it's in some weird
Tupperware or some weird uh I don't like
to see other people's dish
wear in
my I think that's a good I think that's
a good rule to live by yeah I mean like
cookies on a paper plate uh-huh keep it
just keep it eat it in the car ride home
I don't want to see it if I'm having you
over just let me do it bring a little
wine or what have you that that's all I
ask but the food just keep it keep it at
home what do you think is the greatest
of all time Thanksgiving
dessert that Thanksgiving you know what
I like I like a nice pumpkin pie classic
classic pumpkin pie never used to eat
pumpkin pie as a kid about 10 years ago
I start getting into pumpkin pies and
that's that seems to be my favorite and
then finally Seattle plus 82 against the
49ers on Thanksgiving night do you like
the Seahawks to
cover uh yeah I'll take Seahawks to
cover well that's straight that's
straight from the bookie right there and
look at you Sebastian Manis scalo taking
on the wings of death living to tell the
tale and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life well besides the fact that I'm
taking home a beautiful
Acorn from this from this show want
everybody to tune in to bookie on Max
November 30th and uh other than that
have a wonderful Thanksgiving and keep
your [__] food at
[Applause]
home oh man thanks for having
[Music]
me
hot ones fans it's been years in the
making but at long last the next big
thing in Wings is finally here
introducing hot ones buffalo sauce our
spin on Buffalo is a rich and tangy
combo of cayenne peppers distilled
vinegar and yes real butter which means
that you can put hot ones buffalo sauce
directly on wings no mixing or melting
required it's the best damn buffalo
sauce I've ever had in my life but don't
take my word for it camera guy Bill
Buffalo's favorite song gives it to
Blazing thumbs up don't you Bill that's
a Buffalo Bill
guarantee heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the brand new hot ones buffalo
sauce